hello
and welcome to drew crime a true crime
investigation series dedicated entirely
to crimes committed against people named
drew
i'm deborah norville on this episode of
our very
very specific series drew barrymore is
back with the mysterious disappearance
of her dog douglas here's drew i brought
douglas to the studio this morning he
was supposed to join us at the news desk
for a special segment
weighing in on pop culture stories is
very
opinionated and i turned my back for one
minute
and he was gone i figured he was being
briefed by a producer but
the producer said he had been briefed
earlier
i looked everywhere and that's when i
knew
he was gone where oh
where had that little dog gone where
oh where can he be drew's dog was
gone dog gone it but luckily
she was about to be thrown a bone here
again
is drew i just don't know where he
could be i just woof
bark woof woof douglas gets treats every
day this week
wait there's something wrong with the
prompter douglas
where have you been and why are you
dressed like that
and when did you learn to operate the
prompter
you were in hair and makeup getting in
disguise
no one will know this is you oh you
wanted a disguise so you could pose
as the prompter operator and change the
script to be about you getting treats
and such
well that's pretty doggone smart and you
look
positively ferocious
[Music]
that's it for this episode of drew crime
join us next time for
wolf barker what the [ __ ]
douglas oh this little guy's in the
doghouse
i'm sorry it's okay puppies
douglas
you